moi je ne sais pas quoi dire des
messages d'alerté qui ont été retrouvés
sur les produits au niveau des
étiquettes c'était messages qui ont été
gravées par les ouigours et peut-être
d'autres employés dans d'autres pays on
peut voir le messager besoin de votre
aide
si la première et la dernière fois que
je commande sur ce que c'est normal
qu'il écrit ça sur l'étiquette alors
chine c'est une les normes industrielles
et millions et des millions et des
millions de doses de pièces évidemment
fait en chine donc le code du travail
est très relatif mais alors la marque a
quand même répondu en expliquant que ce
n'était pas tout à fait vrai pas tout à
fait faux il était un peu il était un
peu border with your way est plus en
plus de messages à l'être comme ceux ci
a même une femme qui a laissé son numéro
de téléphone pour qu'on l'appelle donc
c'est terrible il ya énormément de
marques américaines et européennes qui
font encore travailler des personnes à
l'étranger ou souvent des ouigours dans
des conditions qui sont des as causé
c'est honteux ils feraient mieux de
revenir un peu sur leurs marges et payer
les gens correctement enfin c'est
honteux toutes les marques donc on a
bricolé à die das nahdiste noah qui
circulent sur les sur les mêmes
étudiants et même dans le dans le dans
le luxe c'est pareil mais sur et
fabriqués à l'étranger cela dit il ya
beaucoup d'hypocrisie parce qu'on le
sait tous on n'a pas besoin d'être
marquée sur les ittig les étiquettes is
your help et tout ça on le sait que ils
utilisent des enfants du travail forcé
il n'y a pas de code de travail le
cheminent que c'est une dictature etc on
le sait mais on achète quand même les
marques nike et adidas et le don de soi
qui alors s'ils sont fabriqués dans ces
pays là à moindre frais et voilà c'est
bien ce jeu compliqué on sait très
écrite
jaguar et land rover serait également
concerné et on sait que jaguar et land
rover sont deux fournisseurs officiels
du palais de buckingham ils sont ce
qu'on appelle le royal world et le
palais de buckingham est en train de
regarder attentivement la
plus de 100 missions qu'on sait donc ils
font partie de la liste noire
voilà parce que les jaguars sont faits
en chine mada il y aurait des noms
lapiaz et
du thin en chine qui en est fait aux
frais
c'est pour ça que si on a la liste en
fait de ses marques là et qu'on aime
quand même consommé ses marques ce
serait bien de les consommer uniquement
sur du comment dire sur de la seconde
main parce qu'aujourd'hui la seconde
main sur les vêtements ça se fait
beaucoup donc si on m a dit d asthme
pourquoi je suis le quatrième sur
certaines plates formes plutôt que
d'acheter du neuf mais le problème ça se
fait ça irait plus vite de dire quelle
marque ne fait pas ça parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout pardon il ya des
marques qui rebondit s enfonce en
français oui quoi ton production qui
sont dans les normes tout à fait une
tresse à quatre tous fait pas ça à quoi
je veux dire mais bon est-ce que
honnêtement vous faites attention à tout
ce que vous achetez malheureusement non
jeanne moreau par qantas a par exemple
on vient donner à tout le moins possible
voyez jamais se joignent à la demande
résultant s'est passé pas plus mal
habillé je résiste j'essaie d'aider
justement n'y avait pas d'étiquette
vraiment eu alors une langue assure elle
vous magali qui est à peu près beaucoup
de chose tous les jours
vous ai pensé pour ça alors oui j'ai
fait alors oui non mais je suis honnête
avec vous et transparente je vais pas
mentir ça sert à rien mais j'ai fait une
promotion il ya très peu de temps pour
que pour sin est en fait quand j ai
posté devant moi je peux pas deviner ça
on s'éclaire avait pas et j'ai reçu une
tonne de messages suite à la vidéo qu'il
a fait après c'est difficile de se
positionner parce que j'ai aussi reçu
des messages en dix ans mais il ya on a
trouvé la même chose chez zara on a
trouvé la tête chez intel chez intel
donc après on dit aux
cadeaux du coup on se dit ok alors vous
avez raison les marques françaises il y
en a qui revendique bien sûr une
fabrication française après je pense
qu'elle pouvoir d'achat aussi des
français qui fait que la marque
française elle peut pas vendre des
t-shirts à 5 ou 10 euros c'est ça donc
forcément la personne peut pas se les
payer donc va être obligée de se diriger
vers des sites qui vendent moins cher
parce qu'on sait que le smic français
est très bas donc c'est compliqué est ce
qu'on doit propres moi je me suis posé
la question est-ce que je dois continuer
à promotionner où est ce que je dois
arrêter et en vrai c'est un peu fou
parce que on sait pas en fait c'est
s'améliorer vite on m'a chérissez france
était bien
même tu sais très bien que aujourd'hui
très peu de personnes en france peuvent
se permettre de s'acheter en tee shirt
chez dior donc à un moment donné alors
alors il y avait une marque en france
qui faisait des idées de déco gros
prises et étatique a disparu
par uniqlo par tout savoir que là et qui
a disparu des rues totalement c'était un
moyen de s'habiller pour battre auxerre
c'est juste une petite info intéressante
puisque l'on est très intéressant si si
parce que notre ami bertrand a évoqué
jaguar et land rover effectivement la
figure où je vais voir je pensais que
c'était allemand effectivement ça avait
été racheté par bmw et bien maintenant
ça appartient à l'indien tata
motors alors autant aux tons jaguar
j'aime bien mon
fils alors quoi excusez moi je peux
donner l'info pardon au nom d'allah est
quand même pour la patrie est ce que
quand même
nom mais par rapport à la chine ce que
tu disais c'est très intéressant et
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait parce que
justement maintenant dit commotionnée ca
ou en fait ils sont la seconde main
series ont créé des pop up store en
france ou en fait tu va ramener tes
habits de quelques marques que ce soit
et du coup tu peux échanger avec les
habits que les gens vont déposer et ses
chaînes qui fait ça c'est ça voilà on
n'en a pas beaucoup d'argent mais ça
c'est du troc ou exactement et c'est
vrai qu'on a sponsorisé par don acheter
ou alors si on a plus je te disais juste
tout à l'heure que j'adore ton tee shirt
jean pascal il m'a dit bah moi c'est un
t-shirt recycler tout donc en fait il ya
plein de plastique qui font soit du 100%
française pas qu'il faut du recyclé donc
faut faire la promotion de certains
événements cette semaine à des consignes
par rapport à ça et c'est vraiment
pourquoi mais c'est seconde main et
c'est des échanges